Christmas it's a time of families coming
together and people putting their feet
up and relaxing if only for just a few
days however it could also be a tough
time of the year for many in the UK both
personally and financially and for that
reason many people here also try to make
an effort to help their fellow citizens
in this festive period one such
initiative also seeks to strengthen ties
between culturally different communities
we thought why should anyone in
Christmas especially children be
deprived of this festive feeling and so
by providing them with the gifts we can
try and you know lessen their pain by
drawing a big smile on their faces this
initiative has been put together by the
a Lacroix Foundation a sheer Muslim
youth group based in North London it's
all about coming together with other
like-minded people and wrapping presents
to be handed out to families in need as
well as in local hospitals and to
children in foster homes the organizers
say it's a part of their faith to reach
out to others particularly those in need
the campaign was Accord gifts from
messenger highlighting the intimate
relationship between Islam Muhammad and
Christian teased Jesus and at the end of
the day we hope that we can build
bridges to become a positive asset to
society in London one local priest is
enthused by the message of unity that
this event sends I think it's just
absolutely typical of the Muslims that I
know that they respond to others with
compassion and with mercy and for me
that's an important issue that if those
are the qualities of God then you try
and replicate those qualities of God so
to see this is just wonderful news of
recognizing that there are some people
for whom compassion mercy generosity
beneficence all these things are
important in a time of rising tensions
in the world and hate crime on the rise
it's also important to show that those
issues don't represent the whole picture
East Ali RT London
you